[Music]
on this Friday night hate crimes in
Canada the alarming surge of threats and
attacks against Jewish and Muslim
communities nobody in any Community
deserves to live in a state of fear the
latest targets including a school and
the response from politicians and police
a fragile peace shattered the house got
burnt completely with the people inside
Global News gains access to the Israeli
Village closest to the Gaza border as
the humanitarian crisis on the other
side hits a new low Canada's single-use
plastic band trashed why a federal court
bended the Environmental
[Music]
Policy plus from the Prairies to
Saturday Night Live calgarian pop star
Tate McCrae is taking the Music World by
[Music]
storm global national with far an Asser
reporting tonight Jeff simple good
evening and thank you for joining us the
violence and tension in the Middle East
is fueling a troubling Trend here in
Canada and just the last 24 hours both
an Islamic community center and a Jewish
High School in the Toronto area were
forced to evacuate after they both
received threats those incidents are
just the latest in a surge of hate
crimes following the Hamas attack on
October 7th and Israel's bombardment of
Gaza Eric senson has our top story
tonight again the same Toronto Jewish
School threatened a month ago was
evacuated today after a bomb threat an
email claimed multiple bombs had been
placed in the building there were none
but it's another public expression of
hatred nobody in any Community deserves
to live in a state of fear deserves to
live uh go to school or attend a
community center or a religious
institution where there is fear the same
words could have been said by the cab
driver who was stopped in this Toronto
intersection way Wednesday asked if he
was Muslim then sprayed with a substance
in the face these incidents are
increasing a mosque north of Toronto
received threats this week a synagogue
and Jewish Community Center in Montreal
were the targets of firebombs last week
attacks on businesses like Indigo books
and Starbucks are increasing they come
against the backdrop of violence in
Israel and Gaza it's led to protests
across this country for Israelis and for
Palestinians but has also Unleashed
anti-semitic and islamophobic hatred
levels seldom seen here or gunshots
fired at Jewish schools or a terrifying
rise in islamophobia try as he might to
navigate a middle ground there's no
position from the Prime Minister that
hasn't triggered a backlash at a
restaurant this week he was accosted by
Angry protesters today he lamented
what's happening in a country built on
diversity we find ourselves in a moment
where the intensity of the emotions of
the fear of the grief that people are
going through is having Canadians forget
a little bit about who we are authors
one Jewish and one Palestinian are
troubled by the one-sidedness in the
disputes writing recently inflammatory
statements are keeping us siloed in our
tribes that can only lead to Greater
polarization and social disharmony those
who are asking us to take one side and
and and not consider the other
whatsoever are basically asking us to
choose one humanity and ignore the other
Humanity fracture in our discourse is
harming both communities and we need to
do better at the Tannon bomb School in
Toronto the police had a simple plea a
simple message there is no place for Aid
in Toronto there no place for Aid terot
a message it seems that many are not
hearing right now Eric senson Global
News
Toronto the World Health Organization
says it's extremely concerned about the
spread of disease in Gaza conditions
there are deteriorating rapidly with
Israel's ongoing assault
many Palestinians who followed Israel's
evacuation order and fled Northern Gaza
now face strikes in the overcrowded
South the Israeli military pounded parts
of Southern Gaza with deadly shelling
overnight following through on threats
earlier this week of an imminent
military operation the UN warns the
expanded offensive could have
catastrophic consequences and a warning
the video you're about to see is
disturbing Redmond Shannon
reports unbearable
grief Hospital staff in KH unun prepare
more bodies for burial some are young
children gaza's second largest city is
in the southern half of the Palestinian
territory away from the main focus of
Israel's ground operation in Gaza
City we were in Gaza City and because of
the conflict we moved to hunas all my
sisters died and my son and daughter
also I wish I had taken her in my arms
my twin sister also
died this week Israeli Defense Forces
dropped leaflets on Eastern Kan Yunis
warning residents they also need to move
to safety Israel maintains Hamas targets
are hiding in that area but for some
families there was nowhere left to
go British Palestinian Dr rassan Abu has
finally fled Northern Gaza
he says they ran out of anesthetics at
Al AI hospital where he has been working
this month making his job impossible
it's been a living nightmare leaving 500
wounded knowing that there's nothing
left for you to be able to do for them
it's just the most heartbreaking thing
I've ever had to do the Palestinian red
crant says that hospital is now besieged
with Israeli tanks close
by as Israel's raid on the nearby alif a
hospital enters a third day Hamas is
hidden inside the Israeli Defense Forces
say Hamas militants were hiding out and
holding hostages in and under that
complex as gazin are forced to move
around they are crowding into smaller
areas under ever worsening conditions we
are extremely concerned as well about
the spread of diseases the the Ministry
of Health
and reported already over 70,000 cases
of acute respiratory infections over
44,000 cases of diarrhea Israel's war
cabinet said Friday in a response to a
request from Washington it will allow
two fuel trucks a day into Gaza to power
water and sewage systems that's 2 to 4%
of the fuel Israel says Gaza used before
October 7th the country's National
Security advisor says Israel doesn't
want the spread of disease to harm
civilians or Israeli soldiers Redman
Chan Global News
London MERS gathered in the West Bank
City of Janine today for the funerals of
three Palestinians killed during an
overnight Israeli raid hundreds joined
that procession the Israeli strikes also
injured at least 15 others Israel says
the strike targeted Hamas killing at
least five of its members while Hamas
says three of its Fighters died in that
exchange funeral proceed also took place
in Israel today for an Israeli soldier
who was taken hostage by Hamas Israel's
military says the body of 19-year-old
Noah Marciano was recovered from Gaza
earlier this week Corporal Marciano was
reportedly serving as a lookout in one
of Israel's border communities with Gaza
when Hamas began its attack on October
the 7th well today we got a closer look
inside one of those communities nativ
hasara borders gaza's Northern perimeter
just minutes from the once bustling orz
Crossing Israeli officials took
journalists through a guided tour of
that community and our Mike Armstrong
was
there weeks have passed the war has not
driving into nativ hasara a massive
plume of smoke Rose in the distance from
an explosion in
Gaza right now only a handful of
residents is allowed back the man
leading the group is a photographer
Benny Vayner says he'd rather be care in
a camera now it feels like a ghost town
there are no cars and home after home
sits empty but there also homes that are
gone bilha and Yakov yonan were killed
October 7th in the home where they
raised their son the terrorist who came
in they shot an RPG into the house and
the house got burned completely with the
people
inside the attackers that hit nativ
hasara came on paragliders the man who
shot got this video in it is heard
asking where's the Army well everyone
Army included was caught by
surprise 17 people in this community
itself were killed here another two
right by the Sea which is right next to
us and another one that was killed
coming in on our motorcycles altogether
20 people from this community were
killed murdered that home behind me is
the closest in this community to the
Gaza Strip basically 20 or 30 meters
from the wall this is a community that's
so close that over the years when the
sirens go off to alert them that Rockets
are incoming they've got 5 or 10 seconds
to find
shelter now nativ hasara lives with the
wall but it also has a gate one that's
decorated with a mural called the path
to peace well right now anger is making
that path hard to see I'm not believe in
this like this I think it will be a lot
of generations until we'll be peace
the Israeli government has said towns
that are close to Gaza may not be
allowed to return people are being put
up in hotels for 3 months and then could
be moved to New housing that idea is not
going over well when we run away it's me
you lost so there is no option to run
away I mean we left home but we are
coming back Mike Armstrong Global News
nativ Hasa
Israel prime minister Justin Trudeau is
heading home from San Francisco
following the annual Summit of Pacific
Nation leaders known as apek one leader
in particular stole the spotlight
Chinese president xiin ping signaled
that he wants to improve his country's
relationship with the United States but
as our chief political correspondent
David Aken reports China's relationship
with Canada is another
story at a summit a year ago Chinese
president xiin ping dressed down prime
minister Justin Trudeau over a perceived
slight this year things were slightly
better the two leaders didn't say a word
to each other at a summit photo op but
later exchanged pleasantries as they
passed each other in a hallway in
addition to saying uh hello to president
she talked about how we need to keep our
uh officials and teams working together
to try and create constructive dialogue
around issues that matter to uh us
individually but also matter to the
World by contrast she met with US
President Joe Biden for 4 hours and then
spoke publicly about improved relations
with the United States he even committed
to sending pandas to a California zoo
China believes in what it calls great
power diplomacy and it looks at Canada
as either a middle or a small power a
place with which it does not have to
Curry favor as a result here at Apec
Trudeau spent his time improving
relationships with the likes of Japan
Mexico and Australia it is a complex
relationship with China but Canada will
continue to both stay strong anchored in
our values and look for opportunities to
contribute to economic growth and
opportunities for Canadians now that
said just before this summer got going
the Chinese ambassador to the Canada
said that China was ready to have quote
rational relations with Canada though no
details were given and in the meantime
Canada is in the midst of a foreign
interference inquiry and China is right
in the middle of that Jeff David Aken in
San Francisco thanks David world leaders
and dignitaries are also gathering in
Halifax this weekend for an annual
Global Security Summit opening day
focused largely on the war in Ukraine
but there's a growing push to change the
agenda and put the Israel Hamas War
front and center Heidi petk
reports 300 dignitaries and decision
makers from around the world now in
Halifax at a time of global conflict one
the president of the Halifax
International Security Forum says began
with Russia's full-scale invasion of
Ukraine it was the type of attack that
belongs in a different
Century Paving the way said National
Defense Minister Bill Blair for the
deadly attacks by Hamas on Israel
October 7th as he reiterated ottawa's
support of Israel in staging its defense
the price of Justice cannot be the
suffering of innocent civilians and the
Productions of civilians remains
Paramount but hamis but Hamas must stop
using Palestinian civilians as human
Shields this is Minister Blair's first
time at the alifax International
Security forum and he acknowledged that
what he called recent challenges to
rule-based International order won't be
solved here as many protests across the
country continue to call for a ceasefire
in the Middle
East demonstrators in Halifax Gathering
outside a restaurant where Forum
dignitaries went on Thursday night thew
two people were arrested including Mona
Mana who says she just wanted to speak
to her local MP desperate to get her
parents out of Gaza I had so much faith
in the Canadian government that I do not
I can't say I
have anymore I really can't say that CE
fire now this protest outside the for
today small but with more planned this
weekend outside of forum organizers
insist is an important show of strength
in a battle for democracy Blair said the
world can't afford to lose Heidi pic
Global News Halifax first of all
single-use Plastics persist coming up
why the federal government's plan to
phase them out has been thrown
out welcome back electric vehicle
battery plant projects in Canada could
cost a lot more than expected the
Parliamentary budget Officer says
provincial and federal support for
manufacturing in Canada will cost nearly
6 billion above original projections
that report analyzes the cost to
governments in recent deals struck with
northvolt Volkswagen and stellantis to
locate their EV battery manufacturing
facilities in Canada over the next 10
years it pegs the total cost of support
at more than $43 billion rather than the
37 billion previously announced the
shortfall is attributed to Lost
corporate income tax
revenues a federal judge has dealt a big
blow to the liberal government's
single-use plastic ban Ottawa began
phasing out some plastic products after
adding them to a list of toxic items
plastic producers and some Prairie
Provinces called the move government
overreach and a federal court agreed
toia isri
reports the once ubiquitous plastic bag
the grocery store staple has been harder
and harder to come by ever since the
federal government shelved them last
year we didn't have enough time to
prepare the owner of this Ottawa
business made the move away from plastic
but says the alternatives are more
expensive and sometimes less practical
the only thing about the paper bags is
if you're outside and it's raining good
luck your groceries have ended up all
over the floor Ottawa says it's a price
worth paying the federal government
labeled single-use Plastic Products as
toxic because they're hard to recycle it
was a key step that allowed a national
ban Sid stepping provincial Authority on
Waste Management the classification of
PL Plastics as toxic material was was U
not only significant overreach on the
part of government but it wasn't
necessarily informed by uh science or
evidence plastic producers fought the
ban in court with Saskatchewan and
Alberta joining the challenge arguing it
put jobs and investment at risk a
federal judge sided with them calling
ottawa's actions unconstitutional and
unreasonable it really hampers the
government's ability to curb plastic
pollution which as we know is one of the
biggest Environmental crises of our time
there's a patchwork of similar bands
across the country despite the ruling
the big grocery chains don't plan on
bringing back plastic
bags and neither do these Shoppers it
does seem like a step backwards it seems
like we're kind of uh being slow to
react I think we've adapted and we moved
in the right direction and I'd like to
see that continue you know uh cuz
there's so much waste with uh with these
bags the battle over the single use
plastic ban is likely not over the
environment Minister says the federal
government is strongly considering an
appeal teria is re Global News
[Music]
Ottawa still ahead why this unlikely
Christmas duet is striking a
chord the Las Vegas Formula 1 grand prix
got off to a chaotic start last night
qualifying rounds for the inaugural race
were delayed after a Ferrari was badly
damaged from running over a loose
manhole cover action didn't resume until
2:30 in the morning in front of a mostly
empty
grandstand you were handsome you were
pretty you're the king
pH move over Taylor Swift the Kelsey
Brothers have sung their way to the top
of the charts on iTunes Travis the NFL
star who is dating Taylor Swift and Clik
Haden herd joined his brother Jason
who's a Philadelphia Eagles player for a
sibling duet it's part of an album
that's on sale next month called a
Philly special Christmas proceeds go
towards Children's Charities in
Philadelphia from the studio here at the
Alberta ballet to 30 Rock and Saturday
Night Live the rise of Calgary's Tate
McCrae coming up on global
national
[Music]
and that is global national for this
Friday I'm Jeff simple tonight's your
candada features a four-legged employee
at downtown Edmonton's oldest
hotel
treats Hendrick is the new Kine
Ambassador at the Fairmont Hotel
McDonald he was too social for his
career as a guide dog so I'm sure he'll
fit right in at the hotel $5 from each
guest pet fee will go towards Canadian
guide dogs for the blind thanks for
watching
[Music]